المساعي الاوروبيه لانشاء محكمه خاصه
لمقاضاه عدوان روسيا على اوكرانيا حسب
العبارات الرسميه الاوروبيه
قطعت خطوه اضافيه في هذا الاتجاه من خلال
انشاء المركز الدولي للتحقيق في جريمه
العدوان في مدينه الفيفا الاوكرانيه نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي
المركز سيحتضنه مؤقتا مكتب الادعاء
الاوروبي في لوكسمبور ويتولد تحقيق وجمع
الادله وانشاء البيانات حول جرائم
المرتكبه
قطعنا المرحله الاولى المتمثله في المركز
الدولي للتحقيق في جريمه العدوان الهدف
يظل البحث عن الهيئه القضائيه المناسبه
منها خيار المحكمه الخاصه مثل ما طلبت
اوكرانيا او اي صيغه اخرى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لا تمتلك صلاحيه التحقيق
في جريمه العدوان لان روسيا واوكرانيا
كلتيهما ليس طرفا في محكمه لاهاي علاوه
على عضيه روسيا الدائمه في مجلس الامن
المحكمه الدوليه تحقق فقط في جرائم الحرب
والجرائم ضد الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
المساعي الاوروبيه تتجه اذا نحو انشاء
محكمه خاصه حول العدوان على اوكرانيا
لانشاء المحكمه الخاصه حول اوكرانيا اذا
حظي المشروع بدعم الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لكن قرارات الجمعيه العامه ليست
ملزمه ولا تمتلك الامم المتحده صلاحيه
الزام روسيا بالتعاون مع هذه المحكمه دوله
روسيا قياداتها مؤسساتها تتمتع بحصانه
الدوله ولا يمكن لاي محكمه فرض ارادتها
عليها
كما لا يمكن للمحكمه المزمعه محاكمه
قيادات روسيا غيابيا ما يدعو للشك في جدول
المساعي الجاريه الى تشكيلها مشروع اقامه
المحكمه الخاصه لمقضاه روسيا احدث شرخا
كبيرا في صفوف خبراء القانون الدولي
وافتراض اقامه هاته المحكمه الخاصه حول
اوكرانيا سيعزز الشعور بازدواجيه المعايير
في تطبيق القانون الدولي
احتلالات العراق وافغانستان وفلسطين لا
تزالوا دون محاسبه
الفريد العربيه